il était une fois un peu à l'écart du
château là où l'on entend les oiseaux
chanter le lavoir un lieu de la vie
d'autrefois celle du 19e siècle qui
accueille depuis une trentaine d'années
une princesse
alors me françois et séverine de
bretagne ont au début des années 80
commencé à installer des contes de
perrault dans les dépendances le premier
était le petit chaperon rouge dans la
maison de poupée sur le terrain en 2018
dans le lavoir nous avons modernisé
remis au goût du jour avec des sons et
lumières beaucoup de technologies plus
modernes
cette caudal les enfants maintenant
recherche de la technologie il faut que
ça bouge vous soit interactif donc le
comte tatic comme il y à 30 ou 35 ans
qui n'était plus vraiment au goût du
jour aux derniers mois
je ne cache dans cette ferme raconte à
l'animation originale aux dalles et son
histoire prennent vie grâce à un
vidéoprojecteur sa robe devient un écran
3 mois de travail ont été nécessaires
regardez l'histoire du lieu cette fois
ci le personnage parle de lui à la
première personne et peau d'âne apparaît
au public de manière assez étonnante et
va dévoiler son histoire peau d'âne
immortalisé en 1970 par jacques demy
redevient ici celle de charles perrault
c'est un des premiers comptes qui a été
écrit par charles perrault envers la
version en prose a été réécrite au
xviiie siècle n'est pas de charles
perrault et lacets sont les mots de
charles perrault qu'on entend les mots
du xviie siècle
j'ai décidé de ne présenter qu'un
extrait du compte comme on relit le
compte à un lieu de la vie d'autrefois
j'ai évoqué le passage ou peau d'âne se
retrouvent et se réfugie dans une ferme
où elle va nettoyer loges des cochons et
lavez les torchons une partie de
l'histoire à découvrir lors d'une visite
du château et à compléter chez soi en
ouvrant à nouveau son livre de contes de
fées et voir si la princesse vécu
heureux